today the national vaccination program
continues to power past the target we
set
six weeks ago with more than 15 million
people vaccinated
across the uk and once again i pay
tribute to the
astonishing efforts of everybody
involved the gps the
nurses the volunteers the army and the
pharmacists like hardik desai who
rallied local volunteers to vaccinate
three thousand people
in his village hall enticehurst in
sussex while keeping
his pharmacy open and of course i thank
all of you
who have come forward to be vaccinated
this is an unprecedented national
achievement
but it's no moment to relax
and in fact it's the moment to
accelerate because
the threat from this virus remains very
real
yes it's true we've vaccinated more than
90 percent
of those aged over 70 but don't forget
that 60 of hospital patients with covid
are under 70. and although the
vaccination program
is going well we still don't have enough
data
about the exact effectiveness of the
vaccines in reducing
the spread of infection we have some
interesting
straws in the wind we have grounds for
confidence
but the vaccinations have only been
running for a matter of weeks
and while we're learning the whole time
we don't
today as i talk to you today we don't
have all the hard facts
that we need and the level of infection
remains very high with still
more people today more people still in
hospital today
than in the at the peak last april
and admissions across the uk very
important statistic emissions running
at 1600 a day so
we have to keep our foot to the floor
and i can tell you that today
the next million letters are landing on
people's mats right now offering
appointments to the over 65s
and we're also contacting all those aged
between 16 and 64 with underlying health
conditions
as well as adult carers and if we can
keep this pace up and if we can keep
supply steady and i hope and believe we
can then
we hope to offer a vaccination to
everyone
in the first nine priority groups
including everyone over 50
by the end of april and at the same time
we will be giving
second doses to millions of the most
vulnerable within 12 weeks
of the first so this moment is a huge
step forward but it's only a first step
and
while it shows what the country can do
we must be
both optimistic but also patient
and next week i'll be sending out a road
map saying as much as we possibly can
about the route to normality
and even though some things are very
uncertain because we want
this lockdown to be the last
and we want progress to be cautious
but also irreversible so please continue
to stay at home protect the nhs and save
lives
thank you very much i'm not going to ask
chris to do the slides thank you prime
minister
uh first slide please uh
three slides today the first one uh is
just showing the number of people
testing positive
for covid over time and as you can see
on this graph
the numbers are coming down steadily
over time
but they're still at quite a high level
and above the point where it was for
example in september last year
so significant progress but i'm still
quite high next slide please
if we look at people in hospital in the
uk
these this again is coming down of
course this follows slightly later than
the
rates of new cases again
the rates are still very high so they're
around the point
in fact slightly above the point which
they were at the peak
of the epidemic in april of last year
so these are still very high rates but
they're definitely heading in the right
direction
next slide please and finally
on deaths the number of people who've
sadly died
with kovid remains high but is
continuing to go down
so the most recent seven day average
uh was 657 deaths uh still a very high
number
uh but definitely heading in the right
direction this is now below the peak
of the first wave we had last year
last slide please and this slide just
shows
the steady improvement in the number of
people being vaccinated thanks to the
extraordinary work of people
in the nhs the people that the prime
minister is talking about
and i'd very much like to add as
everyone would huge thanks to the
doctors
nurses volunteers and administrative
people who are in making this happen
it is an extraordinary achievement now i
want to just finally to
say how these the protection from
vaccination will build because it
doesn't all happen
in one go the first layer of protection
is people being protected by their first
vaccine but remember this only
starts to work sometime between two and
three weeks later people are not
immediately protected then people will
have a second vaccine and that will
strengthen the level of protection and
also make it more long-lasting so it is
absolutely essential that when people
are asked to go back for their second
vaccine they do so
the third layer of protection out is
we're confident that these vaccines will
produce some
level of protection from transmission we
don't yet know exactly how much
so if people who are vulnerable
meet other people who are vaccinated
that will provide
another layer of protection for them and
finally
further out once we have a high
proportion of the population vaccinated
this will help to reduce the rates of
transmission reduce the risks of big
surges
so this also provides a level of
protection
so vaccinate the more we vaccinate out
in the community the more we protect
those
uh who are potentially vulnerable thank
you very much
thanks very much chris let's uh go to
simon stevens whose
nhs staff have been doing the the lion's
share of of this vaccination campaign
simon
thank you prime minister 15 million
vaccinations in 10 weeks would be
an enormous undertaking at any time but
doing so during the course of this surge
of winter coronavirus
when the health service has been under
the most intense pressure
and hospitals have looked after more
than a hundred thousand severely ill
coronavirus patients in just the last
month
that really has been an extraordinary
national team
effort and for families and patients
across the country
you've been able to see for yourselves
uh the speed and the precision
with which the vaccination campaign has
been undertaken
so i joined the prime minister and the
chief medical officer in
thanking everybody who's been involved
of course
our gps our nurses our pharmacists
the entire staff of the health service
but also our partners
the volunteers the local authorities the
local businesses the armed forces and
many others who've rallied around
to get us to the place that we are today
but today as the prime minister said is
definitely not a mission accomplished
i've described the vaccination campaign
as two sprints
and a marathon we've just come through
the finishing line of the first
sprint and now we've got a second sprint
between now and the 30th of april
to extend the number of vaccinations
given to the
higher risk groups of the population
before then
moving on to the marathon which will be
vaccination for
everybody in the country who's eligible
as well as
the winter flu campaign and potentially
further covet booster shots this autumn
if that's what the science
suggests is needed so perhaps i can just
spend
a moment on what this next sprint looks
like the 11 weeks between now
and the end of april we're going to be
doing three things
first of all if you're in one of the
groups who've already been asked to come
forward for vaccination and you're one
of the
few people who haven't chosen to do so
you still
can do that so although as the prime
minister says
uptake has been fantastic we thought
that perhaps three quarters of people
would accept the
offer to be vaccinated for people aged
17 above as the prime minister says
that's over
90 nevertheless if you haven't yet taken
up that opportunity
you still can do so get back in touch
with
the nhs with your local gp and that will
be arranged
the second thing we're going to be doing
between now and the end of april
is making sure that people get the
second booster doses
for those who have already had their
first dose and that will particularly
begin from uh early to mid-march
as 12 weeks on from the first
vaccinations
occurs we are reserving the vaccines
that are needed
for that and you will go back to
the same place where you had your first
vaccination
and if you don't already have an
appointment for that don't worry
the nhs will contact you to set up that
second booster shot
and then of course the third thing we're
going to be doing between now and the
end of april
is extending the offer to a larger group
of people
in fact more people are in this next
group than we've
vaccinated in the first group since the
beginning of the program through to
today and for people aged 65
to 69 as the prime minister says you
will be getting
letters today tomorrow this week
inviting you to book in for your
vaccination
in the first instance we are inviting
you to consider doing so at one of the
larger vaccination
centers or the pharmacists who are part
of the program
but if that's not convenient for you you
can hold on and you will be contacted by
your
local gp the reason we're doing that
is we want the gps who together have
done about three quarters of all the
vaccinations so far
to use the next several weeks to focus
particularly
on more than six million people who have
got
underlying health conditions that put
them at higher risk
and given the relationship they've got
with their local practice
and the long-term health conditions that
the gps are already familiar
with managing that makes sense for the
gps to be focusing on
that group of people over the next
several weeks
those for example are people with
diabetes with heart problems
with severe learning disabilities or
mental illnesses
if you're in one of those categories
your gp
locally will be in touch with you asking
you to come forward for vaccination
but we're also going to be offering
vaccination to
younger adults living in care homes or
communal settings
as well as to eligible adult carers
and they will be also contacted by
letter
through the national booking service
so in a nutshell wait for the nhs to get
in touch with you
invites will be on a rolling basis when
it's your turn
because in this uh next phase this
second sprint
actually we're going to be vaccinating a
larger number of people
than in the first sprint and overall
although supply will vary
uh week to week and we'll have to adjust
accordingly we may be giving
up to twice as many vaccinations overall
given we've got to be doing the second
doses as well
than we've done in the first sprint so
i think in conclusion a big thank you to
the public
for helping us get this right an
enormous thanks to
staff and volunteers and partners across
the health service for getting this done
and if you'll forgive coining the phrase
the prime minister i think what
my colleagues across the health service
are saying is give us the tools the
vaccines and we will finish the job
well thank you very much simon we
certainly intend to
do everything we can to give you give
you those vaccines
let's go to sarah from beijing state
given the likely need for an autumn
covered vaccine booster
and then possibly one annually
thereafter how will the nhs cope with
the ongoing pressure to vaccinate
millions of people quickly
on an almost never-ending cycle and be
able to resume a more normal health
service provision at the same time
well thanks sarah my instinctive answer
is the nhs
already uh runs massive vaccination
programs for
uh for flu every every year but perhaps
so
uh chris and simon might want to answer
that one chris you want to go first
so i get a medical answer yes i'm sure
you know i mean
uh in terms of uh covered revaccination
there are
there are essentially two reasons
potentially to do this
uh one of which is if immunity is
starting to wane and we don't really
know how long
we will have to have between
re-vaccinations it might be long period
it might be short this too early
really to tell and the second reason is
if we
end up with uh variants of the virus
that can escape around the immunity
which the vaccine provides
and there's i think reasonable evidence
that we may have to do that this year
because there are several variants that
look very similar to one another
in many ways which actually could have
slightly reduced not completely reduced
but slightly reduced or
in some cases more than slightly reduced
effectiveness from the vaccine in which
case we then
redesign the vaccine scientists
redesigned the vaccine
and that allows to re-vaccinate against
the new variant
but how regularly we will have to do
this and whether it has to be the whole
population
or as it's more common with for example
flu
just limiting it to those who've got the
highest risk from health
we'll have to see and it'll probably
vary uh year by year but i don't think
they should be seen as we're having to
do something on this scale
continuously i think it'll be more
limited and dependent on how frequently
you have to do it
so just adding to what chris has said i
think
the first thing to say is that we've
obviously got many thousands of
volunteers who've come back to help
and even if not all of them are
vaccinating right now
over time during the course of the year
we will be asking them to
uh help out this morning i was in oxford
at one of our vaccination centers
the st john's ambulance doing a
fantastic job uh training volunteers to
help with the program
in coventry on friday where i was
talking to a retired nurse who'd come
back to help
so i think we can expand the number of
people who are helping
over and above the uh usual uh nhs
workforce
and as vaccine supply increases we'd
expect that
more pharmacists high street pharmacists
will be able to do more of the
uh vaccinations as well in the way that
would normally happen during the flu
season
thanks very much the role of high street
pharmacist is incredibly important
hannah from glasgow more and more people
are feeling the weight of the epidemic
now and seeking support for their mental
health but feeling
totally lost um i'm personally very
concerned about some friends of mine who
have displayed worrying changes in
behavior
but don't know where to turn will the
government commit to a mental health
spokesperson at the next chronovirus
briefing
to set out to the public how they can
access mental health support
well hannah i think that's actually a
very a good idea because
there's no question that as this goes on
and the
lockdown continues uh the stresses and
strains are really
uh alas i think beginning to to tell uh
on
on people and um it's
very important for everybody to realize
that nhs mental health services are
still there for you
uh you should use them uh if if you need
them
uh we've put a lot more uh money into
supporting them into another 500 million
pounds into supporting nhs uh mental
health on top of the
uh 12 or 13 billion uh
investment but it's it's very important
that people
make use of those services uh if they
if they need them uh it's also important
to uh to to reach out to the voluntary
sector
uh the mental health charities that the
government is also supporting they can
be a great assistance as well so hannah
i think you're making a a a very
a very valid point and we'll try and uh
find the right
uh the right person to uh to say
something
uh about how to how to do this and how
to encourage everybody really to look
after
our mental well-being and and try and
keep going through this
uh through this pandemic because i hope
that there isn't that much longer to go
now
but you know clearly people have been
under
uh a lot of pressure and and we've got
we've got to
address that anything you want to add
simon to that or
chris completely agreed um just one
thing just to add just because it's uh
starting today uh is that one of the
next priority groups is people who have
got
significant mental health problems so
things like significant schizophrenia or
uh significant bipolar uh uh
spectrum disorders so i think it's
important that people are supported to
get vaccination
that's obviously separate too and
additional to the points that pm was
making more widely
and just just uh thinking hannah one of
the people that we could perhaps get up
to
uh to talk a bit about how we're
tackling the the issue is dr alex
george who uh who i've been appointed as
uh
as our special uh representative the
government special representative on
these
mental health issues particularly as
they affect
young people so i think we'll get uh
alex up and uh and perhaps some others
as well
thank you very much hannah let's go to
alex forsyth of the bbc
thank you very much prime minister you
say you want this to be the last
lockdown but can you really give that
guarantee given the unpredictable nature
of this pandemic and does that mean
we're looking at a very gradual easing
of restrictions should we rule out
get-togethers and getaways at easter
for example uh alex no i can't give that
guarantee you've of course not because
we're we're battling with a uh with
nature with a disease that is capable of
uh mutating and and changing
uh i'm increasingly confident i'm
increasingly optimistic
about the uh the sheer uh
extent of the uh possibilities are
opening up with
uh with vaccinations uh i i'll be
setting out
as much of a timetable as we can give on
the
on the 22nd and i'm you know i'm
i'm very hopeful that we'll be able to
go ahead uh and
and open things up and and and i'll be
saying that but to say i can
give an absolute uh cast iron uh
guarantee that
uh we won't face further difficulties
and uh
you know have to think harder and deeper
about some problems
uh no hannah uh sorry alex at this stage
i can't
uh but um i don't want people to think
that
uh i'm not optimistic i think there's
been a big
change and uh the
the the big change is that science is
now unquestionably in the ascendancy
over the disease and that's manifested
in all sorts of ways
not just through vaccination but also
with better therapies and they're
getting better
the whole time so you know people should
be
very very much encouraged by what's
going on at the moment
but we want to set out a timetable that
is
realistic and that means one that is
obviously
cautious and takes account of the real
state of the pandemic
i need to add that no fine thank you
thank you very much alex
uh carl did an itv thank you prime
minister
i'd just like to find out how cautious
you intend to be
once you have got schools reopened
fully as you hope to do on the 8th of
march will you wait
then to see what effect the reopening of
schools has
had on the rate of infections before you
open up
anything else and how long might that
take and also do you think that
uh you will be able to announce any
other lifting of restrictions at the
same time as
as you make your announcement whatever
it may be on schools for example
do you think you might be able to tell
people they can at least start
socializing outdoors and one quick one
for
chris witte if i may i think you have
said in the past the first place that we
will see the effect
in the data of the vaccination program
is on the death rate do you think we're
seeing that yet and if not
when would you expect to see it carl
i mean great questions but again really
as i said to to alex or
or perhaps as i didn't say to to alex i
think the the
the we'll be setting out i'll be setting
out as much as i possibly can but we
don't
really yet have sufficient clarity
on the the data to be sure
now today uh as of this monday the the
15th
uh exactly what we'll be able to say to
you on
uh monday the 22nd and
uh that's because the data becomes
clearer
with every day that passes we have to
continue uh to evaluate and also
uh to be absolutely clear with you carl
these decisions uh we will take in the
course of this week but they're not yet
taken and um i would just
humbly advise anybody uh you know
reading
uh accounts of of what we're going to do
or uh
hearing about accounts of what we're
going to do at such and such a time
in the course of the next few months uh
to uh to take them with us a pinch of
salt folks because
uh this is still
speculation when i i explain
on the 22nd uh what we're going to do
you'll be hearing it
directly from me on a specific question
you asked me we're obviously putting
a lot of effort into trying to link
together data on uh
vaccination status compared to both
admission to hospital as a marker of
severe disease
and of people who die which obviously
happens slightly later
um i think the earliest indications
would imply there's
some effect but i think it's too early
to be able to put a number on that
the obviously israel is particularly far
ahead in its vaccination program
and there there is some evidence of
effects we would expect to see
some evidence that is strong enough to
be able to put into the public domain
uh in the next few weeks thanks carl
sam coat sky prime minister you warned
this morning that no vaccination program
is a hundred percent effective
can you just spell out what you mean by
that and the implications of that
and professor chris witte what are the
implications of this for protecting
public health do you think some social
distancing measures will now become
permanent
thanks very much sam well i'll ask
obviously i'll ask
chris also to comment on this point
about the effectiveness of vaccine
vaccination programs um
but clearly there will be some people if
you have a vaccine
a vaccine that is that is 80 or 90
effective whatever the
the figure is there'll be at least some
people logically who will
uh not uh benefit from it as much as
others
we think and therefore you know there's
no vaccination program that we know that
is 100
uh effective in protecting everybody who
gets the vaccination
from disease we think and we have good
reason to think that
both the vaccines were you currently
using also
obviously there are more coming down the
track both of them
are effective in offering you a high
degree of protection
against serious disease
or or death and that's a that's a great
thing
uh we're unable at the moment uh
sam precisely to to quantify
what that means in terms of driving down
the incidence
of uh the pandemic in this country how
fast
uh that can go and and that's why
we just have to be cautious at the at
the moment
as chris was just saying we've seen
we've got some
straws in the wind there's some
interesting data uh from
from israel israel but
we we just need to wait a little bit
longer before we can
talk with authority about the
effectiveness of the overall
program we know it's going to work this
it's the speed
at which it works is really uh what it
was still
uh waiting to to see i think it's fair
to say
and in terms of um uh the well firstly
on the general point about the vaccines
uh the effect of this as i try to lay
out right at the beginning will build so
people's first vaccines second vaccines
then when they meet being vaccinated and
the whole population
being vaccinated in the longer term we
hope the whole world being vaccinated
because
it has been repeatedly said and rightly
said that no one is safe until everyone
is safe
but what that means is this the risk
will gradually go down so it won't
suddenly move from a
uh you having to do everything to
nothing this is going to be gradually
little by little we will de-risk it
and other bits of medical science like
improved treatment
uh trial positive trial results last
week for example really excellent news
about oculus map
the effects of all of these together
will gradually reduce
the risk of this but uh it will whether
it'll get it down to the point where
it's zero for all time or whether it'll
take it down to a very low level where
there's some residual there's scores or
a level
where very occasionally you have to do
things in particular points in the
season for example
i think it's too early to say clearly
the hope is we get to a point where the
minimum
effort is used by things like any kind
of social distancing
and by far the majority or all of the
heavy lifting
is done by vaccination drugs and the
basic things like washing hands which
people should be doing anyway
what's the name of that drug again chris
what is it man chocolate is a map
talk talk is told begin you get this
right man
is it talk talk zulu map near enough
yeah
something like that okay this is the one
we gotta get we've got to make sure we
get this right
talk take a listen man toki lizzy map
there you go okay we're gonna have to
know that as well as we know dexter
method
tokilizumab folks that's the one and
that and that helps to drive down
uh mortality as well on top of the
steroids already another
very good trial done here in the uk
thanks to the nhs and the national
institute for health research nihr
tokuluzumab okay good thank you uh
jasmine uh cameron celestia from the ft
thank you we know that there are main
ongoing concerns surrounding vaccine
hesitancy
and uptake particularly among ethnic
minorities and social care workers
currently there isn't publicly available
nhs data detailing how many people have
turned down
their offer of a vaccine would the
government be open to publishing more
detailed information on vaccine uptake
on what specific steps has the
government taken to address issues
relating to vaccine hesitancy and the
spreading of disinformation
particularly among minority groups and
lastly
prime minister you said this morning
that the government wouldn't be keen on
using vaccine passports within
facilities such as pubs
but how does the government intend to
prevent companies from mandating that
all employees or customers
have to have some form of proof of
vaccination before being able to use
their services
thank you thanks um
sorry well it's time once you get the
first so jasmine you're completely right
there is a real concern about the
um hesitancy on the part of some black
and south asian
uh communities uh to accept the vaccine
offer that they're receiving either at
work if they're a health and social care
worker
or as a member of the public what is
happening about that
is that there is a huge effort involving
community leaders
faith leaders the way in which the nhs
itself is administering the vaccine
program
to overcome that and although the start
was slower in terms of the uptake in
some of those communities i think we are
now seeing
meaningful progress for example in
hackney this past weekend
we were vaccinating at a mosque and also
at an orthodox uh jewish
uh site after uh shabbat finished
vaccinating up until midnight
i was uh with uh one of the lead imams
uh this morning in oxford uh who'd
arranged for a
uh zoom uh with one of the top shakes
in the world to help explain why uh
vaccines are safe as well as why they
work
so i think this will build momentum and
let's face it part of what we're up
against is a
jewel epidemic we're up against the uh
epidemic the pandemic of covid
and we're up against a pandemic of
disinformation and the deliberately
sowing of mistrust and we've got to
fight both with equal vigor
on your data point by the way we do
publish weekly the
uptake by uh different ethnic groups
and at a local area we share with local
directors of public health the uptake
uh in a very granular way while
protecting people's medical
confidentiality
and we're certainly going to continue
publishing uh more and more data as we
have it
uh while nevertheless as i say
protecting individuals and families
own confidentiality
yes this is absolutely essential and i
think
just to repeat in a sense something
which uh simon said
um many people may not take it up
immediately but will take it up
subsequently so it's not a matter of
refusal it's a matter of thinking about
it
and then actually moving on to do so all
of us
think this is critical to support people
to make sure we combat
uh misinformation in fact the next
meeting i've got this evening
after this one is with leaders of the
medical uh profession from
lots of different ethnic groups to share
experiences and share how we can work
out
how to make sure that people are getting
absolutely accurate information
that makes clear that the risks of the
vaccine
are massively lower than the risk of
getting this infection and the vaccine
will protect from this infection
and in the long run that is the way we
actually need
to combat this disease is by the much
safer route of vaccination
rather than the very significant risks
that go with this infection for many
people
and jasmine on your very good question
about um vaccine passports which
obviously a lot of people are talking
about now around the world
and in this country some countries
clearly are going to
be wanting to insist that people coming
to uh their country
uh have a evidence of a vaccination
just as uh people have insisted i think
in the past that
uh you have evidence that you're
vaccinated against yellow fever or uh
or or other diseases i think for
purposes of
of of this country and and doing things
within the
domestic uk economy i think what we're
we'll look at everything but what we're
thinking of at the moment is is
is more of a route that relies on um
mass
vaccination and as you know we intend to
vaccinate
uh all the adults in the in the country
uh
by the autumn um plus
plus uh lateral flow testing or testing
uh rapid testing uh for those
bits where you know it is that have been
the toughest nuts
to crack as it were such as uh
nightclubs or theaters
those parts of the economy we couldn't
get open uh
uh last year and um
i think that will be the the route that
we uh that we go down and the businesses
will go down and you're already jazz
been seeing lots of businesses
are using uh the potential of of rapid
uh on the day testing as well i think
that in combination
uh with vaccination will probably be uh
the route forward
i want to stress to everybody it is
still early days there's lots of
discussions
uh still to be uh to be had uh can we go
to
uh dominic yeatman of metro thank you
prime minister those in hotel quarantine
will be tested on days
2 and 8 of their stay and will have to
remain
for another 10 days if they test
positive will they be charged
extra on top of the 1750 pounds if their
release is delayed
what if they can't pay and what mental
health provision is being provided for
people stuck
alone in a room for so long and a
quick one for simon if i may uh the uk
has been vaccinating
excuse me an average of uh 435 000
people a day
since early january uh at the current
rate we could vaccinate over everyone
over 50 by the end of march
and still stay on track with second
doses
but the target date is the end of april
uh why is this do you expect a a slow
down in the rollout
i'll leave that one i'll leave that one
too i'll just quickly do the point about
um
um people in hotels uh
dominick you're worried about people who
may be asked to stay on for longer
because they test
their tests positive i think
obviously you've just got to bear in
mind that uh
it is currently illegal to travel abroad
for holidays anyway
uh we would expect people uh who who are
coming in
uh from one of these uh red list
countries
uh to be able to cover their costs as
for uh
mental health care provision um
that you know that is very important and
i will make sure that everybody has
access to
to the treatment and to the support that
they need
so i i would say dominic two things the
first thing is
as you pointed out as well as opening up
the invitations to more than 14 million
new people in england in the uh groups
that we're
now talking about we've also got the
second doses to administer for those
who've had their first dose
and when we look at the likely vaccine
supply that we will have available to us
uh between now uh and the end of april
uh that
appears to be um what we can do if
supply increases then we think we can go
faster but
that at the moment is represents still a
doubling
of the number of vaccines delivered over
the next 11 10 or 11 weeks compared to
those that have been delivered over the
last 10 weeks so it's a pretty
substantial ramp up in this second
sprint that we're about to embark on
thank you both uh alastair smoot of
reuters
hi alastair smart from raiders thanks
for this um firstly to the chief medical
officer
as we've been hearing data on the real
world impact of vaccines in reducing
deaths but also transmission
will be key in drawing up this roadmap
out of lockdown
can you go into the specifics on how you
work out if it's vaccines bringing down
these numbers and reducing transmission
or if it's only falling because everyone
is under a national lockdown
and to the prime minister um on the
world health organization's
investigation
in china into the origins of the
pandemic you've said that you support
u.s president joe biden
in the need for transparency who do you
hold responsible for the lack of
transparency so far
and what actions are you planning to
take thanks
chris you want to do the question about
that the first one i mean there's an
extremely long
answer uh the short answer is initially
the studies are being done with
something called case control studies
uh but um what we will hope to see
them in time is we'll actually see in
order the rates going down of severe
disease and
mortality exactly following the the
order in which people were vaccinated
and i think what we really want to get
to is the point where we can see in a
sense with the naked eye
the big effect of the vaccines rather
than having to do quite uh
complex calculations uh of of the
vaccinated against the unvaccinated
which is where we are at the moment so
that's very much the direction of travel
but if you look at the data for example
from israel
you actually can see the effect in the
uk we can calculate an effect but it'll
be much better when we can actually see
it when it's big enough to actually be
able to see
what we are seeing i think in some of
the early data from the nhs
is uh what looks like a signal in terms
of the impact on vaccination
but we really want to let the clock run
for another
uh week fortnight to be able to properly
validate that
and impact on transmission will take
longer to determine an impact on
mortality and severe disease
so uh alastair on your question about
uh what happened and how to and uh who
to uh hold accountable for
for for transparency i think it it's
fairly obvious that the
at the moment that uh the most of the
evidence seems to point to the disease
having originated
uh in uh in wuhan that seems to be uh
where the consensus is at the moment uh
therefore i think we all need to see as
much as we possibly can
about how that might have happened uh
the
uh the zoonotic uh questions that people
are
asking i think we need as much data as
as possible and i think what the world
does what are we going to do about it
aleister i think what the world needs to
see is a general agreement
on uh on how uh we
uh track data uh of surrounding
zoonotic pandemics we want uh zoonotic
research hubs around the world and
uh we want a general agreement on on
transparency and i think one of the
the attractive ideas that we've seen in
uh in the last few months has been
a proposal for a a global treaty on
pandemics
so that countries that say that
signatory countries uh make sure that
they
uh they contribute all the the data they
have and we
are able to get to the bottom what's
happened and stop it happening again i
think that that is the
sensible thing to do okay everybody
thank you
very much indeed thank you
there we are that's the prime minister
telling the country that the vaccine
rollout is
an unprecedented national achievement
but he said the level of infection
remains very high
he said there was not enough data on how
or to what extent the virus spreads
after vaccination so transmission
clearly is still an issue
and the numbers in hospital he said uh
with covert exceed
or chris chris whitties were roughly
level with
the numbers in hospital during the april
peak
so said boris johnson we must be patient
and next week i will set out a road map
in as much detail as i can we want this
lockdown to be the last he said
so we want progress to be cautious but
irreversible
that is becoming the phrase of the
moment
the chief executive of the nhs simon
stephens
said today is not mission accomplished
it is a marathon not a sprint let's
bring in
uh deputy political editor sam coates uh
at westminster so sam
the overwhelming message is uh
steady as we go
absolutely mark there's lots of
interesting stuff in that press
conference
uh let's pick out a few highlights first
of all he was of course celebrating the
first 50 million vaccinations and
setting the new target
end of april for everybody uh the next
million letters ending ending today
cohorts one to nine done
uh before may but what was fascinating
was
that one of the questioners was asking
uh about the
pace of the vaccine rollout saying look
you've got a
uh target at the end of april for the
first nine cohorts
at the current rate you're going to hit
it at the end of march
and fascinatingly simon stephens said
well if we can go
faster we will that rather chimes with
people in vaccination centers i was
talking to you today saying they're
actually ahead of schedule
uh even the very ambitious schedule at
the moment so some optimism in
government that they are making
huge strides providing that supply
is maintained the next thing was chris
whittie uh going through his slides he
was making the point
that for all of the good news in terms
of hospitalizations
we still have more people in hospital
because of coronavirus than we did at
the peak last year
and that will be one of the great
limiting factors stopping the government
going
too fast when it announces its
coronavares lockdown lifting map on
monday that that
the fact that uh many many people still
remain in
uh uh hospital with severe conditions
and then there is this question about um
what does the fact that as the prime
minister admitted uh this morning
that vaccinations don't completely cure
coronavirus they're only going to be
effective he said today tonight 80
effective uh lots of vaccines no
vaccine eradicates coronavirus
completely he said now it's a bit too
early to work out
the consequences of that other than us
uh hoping that we're going to drive down
infection rate but professor chris
whitty was fascinating
on this point if you've got some
residual coronavirus circulating in
communities
what happens then and he said
longer term we hope that the whole world
will be vaccinated
and no one is safe until everybody is
safe
the risk will go gradually down we want
to get it down
uh whether it goes down to a point of
zero or that there will be some residual
risk or we have to do things every
winter season
well it's too early to say i don't think
there are many
uh people who were particularly
enthusiastic at chris
chris witte however gently raising the
prospect of annual
social distancing restrictions because
of coronavirus uh he did say it was too
early to say
that we were there but clearly the
government is thinking about the idea
that coronavirus continues to circulate
pretty much forever yeah as you say lots
of interesting stuff but this phrase
cautious but irreversible uh this is
boris johnson is it saying to these mps
who are pushing him look
we're going to take it easy but there
won't be another
lockdown so will they buy that i suppose
is that is the question
i mean we wait and see there's a lot of
juncturing behind the scenes
but i think it's worth pointing out this
that phrase cautious but
um uh it is designed entirely uh
to try and signal to tory backbenchers
to the public that boris johnson's gonna
take it quite slowly
uh uh when he sets out his lockdown
lifting map on monday
but at the same time irreversible you
know there are scientists behind the
scenes who are talking about a fourth
wave about the need for restrictions
this winter next winter
it's very unlikely it's going to be
irreversible um
in some senses today's new phrase is a
hostage to fortune
whether boris johnson can promise not to
introduce certain measures
ever again well i think as the
scientists as chris wetty made clear
it's just too early to say that
and just uh finally sam real concern
still about this uptake or the lower
uptake in black and asian communities
yes i think the government is working
incredibly hard you've seen
uh the first cross-party alliance of mps
uh all uh urging people in the ame
community to take the vaccine
uh and i think that effort will step up
uh as you uh
in the words of simon stevens enter the
marathon phase
of the coronavirus vaccine roll out i
think there is a concern
that you will vaccinate fairly swiftly
perhaps the millions and millions of
people happy to get to it but there is
going to be a residual
group of the population who are
reluctant
gps talk of having to phone people six
seven eight
times in order to actually get them into
the surgeries in order to have their
jabs and i think that
uh will be one of the challenges of the
summer um
quite how you get through uh to the hard
to reach groups fight through the
disinformation that some of them may
have seen
about the dangers of vaccines that are
completely that information completely
untrue
uh and also just reach out to those who
are simply reluctant
okay